[Applause]
um
congrats to on the double xl freshman
man
well deserved arguably you should have
been on it last year
last year you could have been on the
last year
but this year uh i thought they did a
solid job on the cover
there's a few people that you know maybe
you know i thought might might have
could have made it that didn't but
uh how did you feel getting on that
cover like was that something that was
always like a goal of yours
yeah i mean like it's something you look
up to like when you was little like
there's some [ __ ] you seen on youtube
why you staying on youtube looking at
all the freestyle saying
who had the best who had the worst and i
was like i when i get on here one day
i'm gonna know what not to do
like so i've really been prepared for
that like all my life because i was
always thinking like
how would i do if i freestyle like
because i know sometimes it'll be hard
for me to freestyle but i feel like
my double exhale freeze to that [ __ ] i
don't know why this [ __ ] was hard as
[ __ ]
you've been knowing like okay i saw this
guy [ __ ] up
and i saw what this guy did right i
ain't trying to be no me girl
and you know that's hey the double xl
freshman freestyles
it's either great or it's bad for you oh
god a hundred percent
um when you when you did your site for
who were you doing your cypher with
deciphers i was with polo now i'm too uh
what he wanted it was raw wave little tj
um what's her name chica
yeah chica see that's the one let me
redo it food because i kee i
i always forget her name like no i want
to feel like i'm just leaving her out
for
because i she was cool but chica
it was chica
besides yourself did you get this did
you get to see uh
any anyone else's freestyles there like
like
i'm sure you went off but like like were
you like was there anyone else who you
were like yeah that their [ __ ] was
pretty hard
it was like we went in with nobody doing
the freestyles like the freestyles was
by itself
rod wave is singing for sure he was
singing there's no way right like rod
wave is hard
out there i ain't gonna lie on the side
for rod he kind of i think he was
rapping
if i recall he was rapping he went in on
good
i friends i like this [ __ ] though man
that was crazy
yo his voice is incredible shout out to
saint pete